mais d'abord le calendrier des prochains
jours pour emmanuel macron et dans la
perspective du prochain scrutin c'est
avec marion vireux
première étape de cette semaine d'après
élection la publication des résultats
définitifs du scrutin ce lundi puis leur
officialisation par le conseil
constitutionnel
ce mercredi 27 avril ce même jour un
dernier conseil des ministres est prévue
car conformément à la tradition le
premier ministre doit présenter la
démission de son gouvernement d'ici la
fin de la semaine nous a je veux que le
premier ministre met la démission de son
gouvernement et comme je suis
profondément républicain je me
conformerai à cet usage république mais
le bail de jean castex à matignon
pourrait être prolongé de quelques
semaines d'ici à la cérémonie
d'investiture qui doit se tenir avant le
vendredi 13 mai date de la fin du
premier mandat d' emmanuel macron cette
cérémonie devrait être sobre et sera
suivie de la nomination du nouveau
premier ministre qui formera ensuite son
gouvernement premier ministre qui devra
incarner les nouveaux engagements des
manuels mâcon ce sera pas tellement la
question de débauchages ou de
ralliements individuels
ça sera les grands thèmes qui seront mis
en avant le prison l'a déjà dit sur
l'écologie se sera tout en haut de la
composition et de l'action du
gouvernement et dans les profils qui
seront choisies y aura sans doute du
renouvellement est l'incarnation de ses
grandes priorités école hôpital écologie
hop une fois ces étapes passées cap sur
les élections législatives les candidats
ont jusqu'au 20 mai pour déposer leur
candidature la campagne officielle
commencera le 30 mai avec un premier et
second tour prévu les 12 et 19 juin
prochains
emmanuel macron face aux défis d'un
second mandat historique voilà le thème
de notre débat j'accueille sophie de
ravinel bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporter au service politique du
figaro bruno cautrès bonsoir une au
chercheur cnrs au cevipof enseignant à
sciences po j'accueille allemand
frederic dabi bonsoir bonsoir directeur
général opinions du groupe hip hop et
matthieu croissandeau éditorialiste
politique bonsoir monsieur en question
générale qui a dormi plus de cinq heures
cette nuit
la bouche voilà parce que ça c'est le
quotidien ad des observateurs qui
souffrent
et bissau et qui rouvre pas se plaindre
c'est pas la mine où on est très heureux
de faire ce métier on est bien d'accord
allez le résultat officiel je les
données en titre c'est le résultat du
ministère de l'intérieur 58 54 pour
emmanuel macron et dont 41 46 pour
marine le pen sophie de ravinel belle
belle victoire victoire en trompe-l'oeil
quelques ailes qualificative où vous
choisissez une victoire claire et nette
il n'y a aucun doute là dessus avec un
score assez important plus important
même que certains pouvaient l'imaginer
fort ne savait pas trop il y avait des
doutes sur le pourcentage des électeurs
de jean luc mélenchon 2 to soit utile
qui s'est ramassé vers lui savoir quel
serait le taux d'abstention de votre
blanc de votes nuls ou de vote voilà et
en fait il semblerait c'est mon analyse
parce qu'il peut y avoir des avis très
contraire mais le fait qu'il ait ouvert
la perspective vers ce troisième tour
qui est celui des législatives a pu
d'une certaine façon rassurer une partie
de son électorat qui s'est dit bon on
n'a pas réussi cette fois l'urgence
c'est d'écarter le rassemblement
national mais on va se prendre notre
revanche et donc ils ont pu mettre le
bulletin d' emmanuel macron avec moins
de douleur que s'il n'y avait pas eu
derrière ces possibilités de le faire
oui parce qu'ils ont quand même mis à
quoi 40% à peu près les électrons de
chansons et je trouve l'analyse de ce
filtre est passionnante j ai pas pensé
c'est vrai que entre les derniers
sondages pré-électoraux söderling on
était à 55 55 et demi et ce 58 il ya un
petit delta dore son âge est pas fait
pour donner les résultats au point près
même si on est toujours content quand
c'est pourquoi près comme en 2010 est
tombée c'est vrai que dans notre
dernière enquête ont été plutôt sur un
tiers des lecteurs du jury que mélenchon
qui choisissait mâcon série de donner
une perspective ne pas dire que la
présidentielle c'est le la dernière
station avant un long autoroute est un
désert électorale contrairement à 2017
où il n'avait rien dit il avait à peine
à accepter sa défaite souvenons nous ce
soir du 23 avril où ils n'acceptent pas
le verdict des urnes ou ses proches
disent les estimations vont encore
bouger qui pourrait être deuxième alors
qu'il était quand même 4e là il a tout
de suite basculer vers ce combat pour
les législatives une tentative de
compensation en disant cette phrase qui
n'a aucun sens politique mais qui est un
bon coup en disant élisez moi premier
ministre oui parce que c'est pas c'est
pas le peuple enfin une c'est le
président qui choisit directement ne
l'oublions jamais fait c'est
l'expression aussi du groupe majoritaire
au parlement oui bien sûr et d'ailleurs
on sait pas si la perspective une
hypothèse se posera avec des thèmes dont
on va parler mais effectivement est-ce
que emmanuel macron pourrait échapper à
la nomination d'un jean luc mélenchon si
beaucoup de si les cc député obtenait la
majorité bref il ya un autre chiffre que
j'aurais qu'on revoie ensemble parce que
je les dis en titre et vins de mâcon
premier président réélu orco
l'habitation s'éteint un exploit dans
une cinquième république a quand même
été connue pour son dégagisme scrutin
après scrutin mais l'écart avec marine
le pen ça c'est intéressant s'est
fortement réduit il y avait dix millions
de voix d'écart il ya cinq ans il y en a
cinq millions et demi aujourd'hui bruno
cautrès les mâles macron il l'espérait
ce match retour il l'a eu mais l'extrême
droite atteint des sommets jamais
jamais vu et ça il faut aussi le retard
c'est aussi l'un des chiffres à retenir
bien sûr c est même un défi je pense qui
politiquement est le plus important
marine le pen non seulement est arrivé à
survivre à cette élection présidentielle
rappelons nous qu'à quelques mois au
moment de la dynamique eric zemmour
beaucoup de gens disent elle tiendra pas
le choc parce qu'eric zemmour a pris le
leadership
il a créé un mouvement politique
immédiatement du succès ses premiers
meetings sont très réussis donc à ce
moment là tout le monde pense que ça
sera compliqué pour marine le pen
d'autant plus qu'elle était sortie à
s'est abîmé de la précédente
présidentielle et on voit que marine le
pen a été sauvée sans aucun doute par la
profondeur de son ancrage sociologique
les enquêtes qui sont disponibles grâce
à nos amis sondeurs le montre depuis
hier soir on voit qu'effectivement cet
ancrage sociologique communautaire la
carte est impressionnante
impressionnante carte est par ailleurs
toutes les données qui montrent que
marine le pen elle est profondément
ancrée à titre de ces l'élection
présentielle ce sera autre chose en août
au moment des élections légistatives
mais on voit qu'effectivement c'est
devenu un élément pérenne structurels
profonds de notre vie politique et ceux
qui espérait en finir avec marine le pen
ou avec le nom le pen dans la vie
politique française en 2022 pour le
moment devront sans doute être un peu
patient référence à la phrase eric
zemmour hier et il dit par une fois le
nom le pen a été synonyme de défaite
effectivement si on fait un peu frédéric
la sociologie du vote là je préfère
qu'on se concentre sur emmanuel macron
18,8 à peu près un million d'électeurs
alors c'est quoi en quelques brosse le
portrait robot mais vous savez c'est
difficile de parler du portrait robot
des lecteurs macron sans voir son d
kalck whisky lecteurs marine le pen
parce que jamais je trouve un jeu par
son contrôle de bruno qui a aussi des
grandes enquêtes celle de du panel
cevipof on a deux électorats aussi
antithétiques aussi aussi antagonistes
avec une seule l'udc le salat le
salariat du privé où ses 51 49 pour neil
mcmahon marine le pen était arrivée en
tête mais en dehors de ça on est sur des
électorats complètement
antagoniques vous avez un diplôme
supérieur au baccalauréat il ya toutes
les chances que vous avez voté hier
emmanuel macron vous est inférieur au
bac c'est marine le pen votre salaire
dépasse deux mille euros c'est le vote
macron il est en dessous de 1000 euros
c'est le vote le pen vous êtes une
personne âgée vous votez et le maquereau
même si marine le pen a gagné 10 points
par rapport à 2010 est on est vraiment
sur des des véritables dégâts c'est
particulièrement frappant par le passé
il y avait des ouvriers qui voter à
droite le rpr avait une base ouvrière il
y avait des cadres supérieurs ou des
personnes très fortunées qui voter à
gauche on l'a vu en 81 on l'a vu en 88
là c'est extrêmement segmenté 40 points
d'écart entre marine le pen huel macron
sur le vote des ouvriers 30 points
s'agissant des cadres c'est je pense du
jamais vu c'était le cas déjà en 2017
mais ça c'est encore si je puis dire
élargie dans de ce scrutin alors mathieu
on va faire un zoom sur
la victoire des macros on a commencé par
là un n'oublions pas parce que quand on
entend parfois certains commentaires
depuis hier soir il a gagné c'est
extrêmement nettes oui évidemment il a
gagné et la gagner avec un écart quand
même important même s'il s'est réduit
mais on peut dire quand même que le plus
dur commence oui alors le jour se lève
et les ennuis commenceront à l'autre
n'empêche qu'il a dû s'avouer quand même
son bonheur hier soir même à craon lui
qu'on disait être entré par effraction
dans l'histoire de la vème république
lui qu'on disait on l'accusé d'avoir
accompli le hold up du siècle en se
faisant élire à l'elysée mais il a
prouvé qu'il n'était pas un accident
électoral mais phénomène durable dans
notre vie politique c'est quand même le
seul président vous l'avez rappelé à
cette fait réélire sans sortir de
cohabitation oui mais c'était face à
l'extrême droite dira-t-on oui c'est
vrai mais il est en plus responsable de
la montée de l'extrême droite qui
s'égrènent implanté considérablement et
ne cesse de gravir des paliers depuis 30
35 ans surtout la recomposition du
paysage électoral et à l'image en fait
de ce qu'il souhaitait un blanc qu'un
bloc central quasi unique en ayant
siphonner tous les autres partis dits de
gouvernement et puis deux blocs un
d'extrême droite et d'extrême gauche a
on sera peut-être pas d'accord sur les
étiquettes mais dont ils jugent juillet
manuel macron que ces deux blocs là
n'auront jamais de majorité sociologique
alors l'avenir le dira il est permis
d'en douter signe quand on voit que les
écarts quand même se se resserre mais on
est bien obligé de reconnaître au
lendemain de sa réélection que le pari
était le bon le problème c'est que il
s'agit sans doute d'une formidable
martingale électorale pour l'emporter
mais cette nouvelle donne risque de
sérieusement du compliqué la vie pour
présider alors pourquoi s'ils rentrent
en effet madame enfin si elle crée un
nombre considérable de frustration
démocratiques et qu'elle antagonisent
encore un peu plus notre vie politique
on a quand même plusieurs réformes
structurelles et structurante pour les
50 années à venir qui nécessiterait
al'inverse une forme de sinon de
consensus au moins 2 de discussion je
donne trois exemples la réforme
institutionnelle la réforme des
retraites ou encore la transition
écologique et tous les choix qu'elle
implique tout ça ça une portée qui
dépasse de loin celle de son nouveau
quinquennat ça mériterait pour chacune
d'entre elles que toutes les formations
politiques acceptent de s'asseoir autour
de la table ce qui l'a d'ailleurs que
promis comme nouveau fonctionnement le
problème c'est que qu'est-ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement espérer deux parties qui
rêvent eux deux versez cette table la
réponse est dans la question la seconde
limite à vis de ce nouveau paysage c'est
qu'ils ne laissent aucun espace à une
offre politique alternative dite de
gouvernement le bloc national de marine
le pen et le bloc populaire de jean luc
mélenchon propose l'un et l'autre des
changements complets et radicaux de
paradigme alors emmanuel macron a voulu
instaurer à l'idée que c'était lui ou le
chaos mais quand les français sont
lassés de la continuité mais ils
n'auront plus d'autre choix qu'une forme
de saut dans le vide et alors on se
projetait d'en rendre dans les dates là
le calendrier avec marion rigoureux ça
ça peut peser sur l'antenne de son
second mandat évidemment oui on entend
beaucoup qu'il doit envoyer des signes
oui mais lesquelles alors on pourrait se
dire que pour remercier les électeurs
d'avoir reconstitué une fois encore
peut-être la dernière fois le front
républicain il pourrait composer autour
de lui l'équipe issue de deux
sensibilités différentes le problème
c'est qu'il a déjà fait le coup en 2017
en débauchant des figures de droite et
de gauche et que réitérer serait pas vue
comme un signe d'ouverture mais comme la
continuation d'un méticuleux travail de
sape entamé depuis cinq ans et un second
défi qui concerne évidemment les
législatives mais là encore ce gros bloc
central qui la constituent et risque de
finir par l'encombré davantage que que
de notre portée alors je mets des
guillemets tous a besoin dur quand on
dispose d'une majorité c'est quand même
plus confortable quand y'en a pas que
quand on n'en a pas et peut-être leur
at-il mais c'était déjà compliqué à
gérer du temps de l em plus le modem
plus quelques formations lilliputienne
de gauche mais alors si on y ajoute la
formation d'edouard philippe horizons
mais aussi des transfuges de l'air
compatibles et ceux qui m'aiment et
ajoute on dit aussi ce qu'il reste de
sociaux-démocrates qui seront effrayés
par la rupture avec le capitalisme que
propose jean luc mélenchon là ça risque
de devenir carrément ingérable d'autant
pour finir qui mena le maquereau est un
peu à l'image de ses présidents
américains c'est à dire une fois élus
dans leur second mandat ils perdent un
peu de l'aura du charisme et du pouvoir
qu'ils ont sur les autres puisque la
suite peut s'inventer sinon sans lui en
tout cas à côté lui est en tout cas
après lui alors on va écouter tout de
suite un extrait du discours d' emmanuel
macron hier soir
donc il prend la parole vers
21h10 21h15 de mémoire c'est pas le plus
important de tous peut-être 30 en tout
cas c'est pas très important
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que ça laisse
le temps à la régie trouver l'extrait
parce que j'ai changé l'ordre le
conducteur et voilà il parle d'une ère
nouvelle emmanuel macron
c'est avec l'ambition et bienveillance
pour notre pays pour nous tout ce
que je veux pouvoir à vos côtés
aborder les cinq années qui viennent
cette ère nouvelle ne sera pas la
continuité du quinquennat qui s'achève
mais l'invention collective d'une
méthode fondée pour cinq années de mieux
au service de notre pays de notre
jeunesse
sophie de ravinel faut-il le croire ça
pourrait prendre quelle forme cette 7è
renouvelle cette nouvelle gouvernance
promise par emmanuel macron ça commence
mal parce qu'on entend bruno le maire
qui parle de 49,3 à peine emmanuel
macron la réforme des retraites voilà je
suis désolé c'est pour ça que je
m'inscris là dessus en disant
effectivement il ya une volonté de faire
autrement et puis la réalité le rejoint
le rejoint de façon assez assez net et
on ne sait pas ce que ça peut donner
parce qu'effectivement cette réforme de
retraites il a dit qu'il allait la mener
dans les six mois suivant son arrivée au
pouvoir c'est une volonté effectivement
de vraiment et peut-être parce que c'est
son deuxième quinquennat il va pouvoir y
aller parce qu'il n'a peut-être plus
rien à perdre si jamais il ne voulait
pas de ces réformes institutionnelles
qui lui permettrait de prétendre
éventuellement un troisième mandat
encore mais donc on à bruno le maire qui
a fait un peu une bourde sans doute
équivalente à celle qu'il avait fait
pour être tout à fait exagéré pour une
question oui il y répond aux questions
mais ne l'exclût pas l'exclure il dit
mais il avait il avait tout ce qu'il
fallait qu'ils pouvaient sauf oui non
oui dix pages arrive et on
n'exclut pas non plus de la même façon
que sur la la la russie et les rapports
avec poutine il avait été aussi de cette
même manière c'est un peu du même ordre
et donc là on al impression qu
effectivement et à cette grande envie
cette grande volonté de changer quelque
chose mais que la réalité le rattrape et
finalement elle va le rattraper dès le
1er mai puisque il va y avoir toujours
un ces cortèges nourrit le jour de la
fête du travail dès le lendemain de
l'élection et que là jean luc mélenchon
puisque encore lui va profiter pour
nationaliser sinon personnaliser ses
échéances qui sont celles des
législatives qui arrive le troisième
tour social en cette troisième tour
social mais qui aussi vient s'inscrire
dans ce que vous disiez très bien
frédéric de cette fracture terrible
entre justement ces deux électorats
celui d' emmanuel macron et celui de
marine le pen avec même si on a vu qu'il
y avait beaucoup moins qu'on ne
l'imaginait mais une fracture populaire
commune entre jean luc mélenchon et
marine le pen et qui se posera sur la
question de la réforme des retraites et
du pouvoir d'achat qui sont deux sujets
sensibles mais surtout les retraites qui
font descendre les français dans la rue
mais en plus son âme possède un autre
sondage jour du vote il fait fi du ciel
des questions sur cette réforme des
retraites on a un résultat encourageant
pour ml macron qui est presque a foncé
sur deux 45% je trouve ce chiffre élevé
souhaite qu' il ya une réforme qui soit
mise dans les 6 mois donc elle cette
part de la population où on retrouve ce
que j'avais appelé la sainte alliance l
air lr om sur les réformes c'est à dire
cette convergence de vues qu'on a vu
tout au long du premier quinquennat et
qui a froid qui a contribué à fracturer
la droite je rappelle que 40% de
l'électorat fillon 2007 a choisi
emmanuel macron au premier tour c'est
absolument considérable et c'est vrai
que on a d une partie de l'opinion qui
est prêt à bouger mais quand on demande
les des priorités des français en terme
de réformes en table de mesures ce sont
des mesures environnementales qui émerge
des mesures sociétal cette fameuse
question de la fin de vie où ils ont à
un gap jamais vu un hiatus entre
absolument abyssal entre ce que
souhaitent les français es que propose
la loi actuelle et le législateur et
puis comme le dit sophie calendrier
législatif
ça peut être un frère un vrai carburant
électorale pour les oppositions cette
réforme des retraites rappelez-vous
toute comparaison doit être prises avec
prudence mais la tva sociale entre les
détours entre les deux tours par
d'autres telle initiative de 2007 ça
fait perdre une cinquantaine de députés
à la majorité ump de l'époque dont alain
juppé donc ses bottes des ferments
dangereux mais aussi emmanuel macron
tire aussi sa popularité qui est resté
il faut le dire un porte plutôt élevé
même s'il était minoritaire tout au long
de son mandat et deux derniers
fonctionnent repose sur la distinction
et surtout sur la transformation et la
réforme et la réforme des retraites en
étudiant oui bruno cautrès je reviens à
la méthode la nouvelle méthode macro
nice ça pourrait prendre quelle forme
c'est beaucoup plus de consultations des
des français l'utilisation du référendum
comment on peut imaginer ça oui ce sont
les directions privilégiés on a vu au
cours du mandat d' emmanuel macron que
la question de la méthodologie des
réformes c'était bien le coeur du
problème on a vu la crise et gilet jaune
les conséquences qui emmanuel macron
tire le débat national la question du
climat la conférence citoyenne donc ça
va sans doute dans cette direction
emmanuel maintenant voilà mais on a le
souci c'est qu'il l'a déjà fait et quand
il l'a fait à l'issue de la convention
les conventionnels les 150 citoyens
tirés au sort ils ont même noté emmanuel
macron sur sa capacité de mise en oeuvre
c'était pas terrible pour le président
de la république la question se pose
aussi pour le grand débat national toute
la france se pose la question ce grand
débat a été une vraie réussite mais que
sont devenus les conclusions de ce débat
je n'ai pas entendu pendant la campagne
un membre de l'exécutif ou de la
majorité dire on va faire ça parce que
ce sont les français qui l'ont dit au
cours du grand débat national
c'est tout à fait intriguant de ne pas
voir un élément de langage à un moment
donné qui va dans ce sens là parce
qu'une véritable attente une question
que se pose tout le monde ou sousse et
où sont passés les traits cabinda les
rangs des cahiers de leurs ses archives
que par nous voilà donc voilà il ya
cette question n'a est pareil rien aux
problèmes emmanuel macron nous
expliquent en ce moment qu'il veut
transformer de l'intérieur la vème
république
et c'est compliqué parce que de d'une
certaine manière ce qui nous dit c'est
un peu dépossédé le président république
d'une partie des atouts auxquels
emmanuel macron et le plus était attaché
c'est dire c'est moi qui décide c'est
moi qu'un piste on a choisi mon
programme en élisant mais là si d'un
seul coup on ouvre le jeu en disant
maintenant la parole est aux français à
nouveau il faut que j'écoute il ya un
moment donné potentiellement une petite
entaille antagonisme avec la logique de
la vème république comme si emmanuel
macron voulait faire rentrer la vème
république dans un autre moule est donc
là il faut qu'il explicite totalement et
ça se posera à mathieu dès le départ sur
une éventuelle réforme institutionnelle
on voit mal parce qu'il veut réunir tous
les partis politiques autour d'une même
table mais vu les antagonismes tels
qu'ils s'expriment aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qu'est ce qui peut ressortir d'une telle
table ou est ce que c'est ça qui est
très très difficile pour lui alors on
verra ce que donne en tout cas le
résultat des législatives ça se fait
entendre une photographie du paysage qui
tels qu'ils existent aux institutions
strain photographies des formes et
puisqu'on sait bien que le rassemblement
national peut espérer des députés il
peut espérer les doubler les triples et
quadruples et mais on les voit mal parce
que ce qu'on sait que ce que ce mode de
scrutin ne leur ai jamais favorable les
les voir vraiment avec un groupe très
très important idem pour la france a
soumis d'une certaine façon si elle ne
parvient pas à faire alliance avec avec
toutes les autres formations de gauche
et du coup on va avoir peut-être une
grande convention la dernière fois qu'il
a voulu réformer les institutions il a
été bloquée par le sénat français sous
son mode de défense je vais pas plus
j'ai voulu mais ce sont les sénateurs
qui est qui qui n'ont pas voulu jouer le
jeu il va falloir des trésors de
conviction parce qu'on sait que ce
typiquement ce type de réforme ne marche
pas à l'autoritarisme ne marche pas à la
menace ne marche pas odile il faut il
faut vraiment pouvoir composer avec
toutes les formations et et ne pas
oublier les citoyens et quand même ce
chiffre de l'abstention qui est
considérable alors là dedans il ya des
enfants gâtés de la démocratie qu'ils
choisissent de ne pas aller voter il ya
aussi des abstentionnistes qui sont d
une forme de déclassement social tel
qu'on a connus depuis des années ne pas
les oublier cela survie
leur nombre à tous quand même ça défie
quelque chose sur deux des clés pardon
pardon mathieu est donc nominé mais on
peut donner chiffre 13 millions six cent
mille français qui sont pas dépassées on
peut rajouter les 3 millions de
bulletins blancs ou nuls une petite
surprise parce qu'en 2017 il ya des 4
millions de bulletins blancs et nuls et
moi j'envisage est plutôt à un mouvement
encore plus fort qu'en 2017 ça c'est
plutôt répercuter sur l'abstention oui
16 millions de français c'est absolument
considérable et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est la mutation des
motivations de l'abstention entre le
premier et le second tour au premier
tour on a eu cette terrible cause qui
est de la vanité du vote voter ça ne
sert à rien ça ne change plus la ville
offre électorale ne me plaît pas une
sorte d' acqua bonne isme le second tour
céder quand même lié alors que la
campagne avait été plutôt plus active
beaucoup plus intéressante pour les
français jugés de qualité avec 20 points
de plus par rapport au premier tour
c'était quand même la fiche le fait de
renvoyer dos à dos marine le pen eymann
macron avec bien sûr oui une forme de
mécontentement qui a plus touché est mal
macron que marine le pen alors ce qui
est intéressant ce sont aussi et elles
se sont exprimées dès hier soir 1 je le
disais les les attaques les questions
autour de la légitimité du président
réélu l'angle d'attaqué de jean-luc
mélenchon et de ses lieutenants par
exemple alexis corbière c'était ce matin
sur notre antenne
emmanuel macron gagner je le répète
toutefois il a obtenu 38% des électeurs
inscrits sur un corps électoral de 48,7
millions de personnes dire qu'il est
minoritaire et le représentant du
rassemblement national l'a bien dit il a
été élu sur un rejet de l'adversaire
deux tiers des français n'ont pas voté
pour le président de la 5ème république
qui va concentrer énormément de pouvoir
s démocratique eh bien on a une bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on a les élections de
juin pour en rediscuter
est-ce qu'on retrouve quand même un peu
uno cautrès le jean luc mélenchon
mauvais joueur 10 à 5 ans à travers
certain c'est qu'en démocratie
électorale le point capital le point
cardinal de la démocratie électorale
c'est que le perdant accepte sa défaite
non seulement il accepte sa défaite mais
il y voit un encouragement pour
revenir pour retenter sa chance pour
prendre sa revanche même donc ça souvent
le coeur du sujet alors bien sûr on
démocratie électorale pour que le
perdant accepte sa défaite
il faut que la compétition ait eu lieu
de manière fair play à la loyale on peut
pas dire dans notre pays une élection
n'est pas organisée à la loyale on est
une grande démocratie
on a tous les outils pour que tout le
monde vérifie que les élections se sont
déroulées dans les parfaites conditions
de la loyauté démocratique donc
évidemment c'est un argument dont on
voit bien les limites on voit bien pour
quelle raison il est invoqué pour au
fond revenir en se positionner en héros
du peuple celui qui parle au nom du
peuple et qui interprète la volonté du
peuple différemment et qui sait que dans
les urnes le peuple ne s'est pas
totalement exprimé puisque de la ja de
l'abstention à dimension sociologique
également bien évidemment voit aussi le
côté difficile de cette de cet avion
parce que si on commence à expliquer aux
citoyens que l'élection ne donne pas un
mandat légitime ça devient vraiment très
compliqué c'est une autre problématique
de construire fait de concert
politiquement après l'élection de
l'adhésion du sens politique donnée à la
victoire ça c'est une bonne chose mais
par contre l'élection quand c'est à la
loyale le vainqueur est légitime rien on
a vraiment absolument changer d'époque
1974 keith carr destin emporte de 600
mille voix il loue un insecte
extrêmement dur avec des oppositions une
opposition de gauche extrêmement je
tirais tonique mais jamais georges
marchais jamais françois mitterrand qui
pourtant ne retenaient pas leurs coûts
par le président mal élu délégitime la
victoire de giscard d'estaing ça
commençait toute cette affaire avant
loyers de mélenchon ça commence en 2012
avec ta victoire de françois hollande on
entend cette petite musique dès la fin
dès le début de son mandat qui est à
mais enfin qu'il a manqué une semaine à
nicolas sarkozy savait que les courbes
se resserrer entre les deux tours
j'avais été aux journées parlementaires
ump de marcq en baroeul c'était tout à
fait on avait l'impression que la coved
élections allaient avoir lieu quelques
semaines plus tard même chose en 2017 en
disant c'était facile de battre marine
le pen au second tour je trouve que
c'est dangereux pour et ça a été très
bien dit par bruno cautrès par notre
patte démocratique cette non acceptation
d'une défaite le raisonnement selon
lequel
macron nappe a été choisi au premier
tour par 72 % des français est
absolument idiot en 88 françois
mitterrand fait 34 % il écrase tout le
monde en a pas ni 66 % des français
n'ont pas choisi françois mitterrand
sophie davant et nagui je suis
absolument d'accord avec vous deux il ya
un élément - qui vient un peu conforté
ce la critique de sept de ses propos d'
alexis corbière qui est de dire jean luc
mélenchon déjà en 2017 avait
effectivement cette même critique en
parlant de mauvaises élections françois
ruffin après la largement développés
s'étaient beaucoup l'argument aussi des
gilet jaune et on se souvient que c'est
déjà ça infusant look nombre et c'est ça
le vrai rythme ans et jean luc mélenchon
avait tenté il faut s'en souvenir en
2010 est de dire eh bien on va descendre
dans la rue et on va montrer que la rue
est plus puissante que les urnes et ça
c'est vraiment ce danger populiste et de
fait il avait échoué et il avait reconnu
un point à emmanuel macron on se
souvient il avait dû y aura un million
de personnes dans la rue il était à
peine arrivé à cent mille personnes il
avait eu du mal à faire son cortège
peut-être que cette fois ci ce sera
différent mais c'est vrai qu'après il y
avait eu n'ont pas forcément de cause à
effet parce que vous l'avez très bien
expliqué ça remonte à plus loin mais il
y a qui infuse dans l'opinion publique
cette idée que effectivement et
d'ailleurs au premier tour on l'a vu
dans l'abstention les urnes la politique
ça n'a plus d'intérêt là où les choses
se passent c'est dans la rue et on a vu
un peu dans l'ultra gauche en tout cas
hier soir même s'ils n'étaient pas très
nombreux
cette idée de dire cette élection ne
vaut pas ce qui vaut c'est le mouvement
dans la rue et c'est nous qui allons
aller contre le résultat ne nous
convient pas et ben on considère que
l'élection c'est un peu le cas des
étudiants qui qui qui d'ailleurs était
un peu terrible à voir mais qui montre
tout ce qu'ils disent peut être audible
évidemment mais enfin entre les deux
tours à dire on ne veut ni de leur peine
ni de macumba très bien mais ce que tout
le monde d'entre vous bien d'aller voter
au premier tour évidemment déjà alors on
continue de se projeter on l'a un peu
fait ensemble vers les
législatives c'est dans moins de
cinquante jours steve jourdain vous
pouvez nous nous rejoindre va on va
parler de la gauche bonsoir steve est le
troisième jour a déjà commencé à gauche
une fois n'est pas coutume jean luc
mélenchon s'est exprimée très rapidement
et après l'annoncé des résultats c'était
aux alentours de 20h30 il a appelé à la
mobilisation générale pour les
législatives de juin la mobilisation
c'est dire en fait le rassemblement
d'air lui derrière la france insoumise
un rassemblement qui évidemment ne fait
pas l'unanimité à gauche mais pour
ségolène royal c'est un grand oui
écoutez là c'était hier sur france 2
je souhaite qu'il y ait un rééquilibrage
au parlement et comme ma famille
politique c'est la gauche et que jean
luc mélenchon réussit l'exploit de
presque être qualifié pour le second
tour je pense d'abord que tous méritent
et je pense que la recomposition de la
gauche mais au delà de la gauche des
humanistes de ceux qui ne sont pas
forcément dans un camp mais qui sont par
exemple dans la génération climat des
jeunes générations
sûr que cette rencontre position se
fasse parce que c'est la loi
démocratique autour de celui qui est
aujourd'hui est en tête alors pour
ségolène royal mais c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que au parti
socialiste ou chez les écologistes tous
ne sont pas du même avis non vraiment
pas tous regarder ce qui se passe chez
les socialistes après la débâcle du
premier tour ils se sont réunis c'était
la semaine dernière objet de la réunion
préparer les législatives ce qu'il en
est ressorti on va le voir 160
socialistes se sont exprimés pour le
dialogue avec la france insoumise 75 se
sont exprimés contre on compte aussi 10
abstentions et puis il ya une
soixantaine de socialistes qui n'ont pas
pris part au vote on a donc
théoriquement aujourd'hui une majorité
de socialistes qui sont pour une
alliance avec les mélenchonistes une
minorité qui s'y opposent dans cette
minorité on retrouve notamment anne
hidalgo ou encore carole delga la
patronne de la région occitanie on
retrouve aussi un certain françois
hollande écouter à gauche aller elle
doit se rassembler ça c'est un principe
généralement ça c'est au second tour et
faut qu'il y ait une offre qui soit
crédible si l'offre n'est pas crédible
n'y a pas de majorité possible je
rappelle qu'on peut pas se nommer
premier ministre par décret ça ça
n'existe pas voilà alors si une majorité
de socialistes sont pour des discussions
avec les insoumis cet amour n'est pas
vraiment réciproque pour l'instant la
france a soumises a décidé de faire
avancer les négociations avec certains
partenaires à gauche les communistes et
les verts les socialistes pour l'instant
sont sur la touche et comment se passent
ces négociations ça chauffe ça chauffe
te ment entre les écologistes et la
france soumise avec moins de 5 % au
premier tour de la présidentielle les
écolos savent qu'ils ne sont pas
vraiment en position de force il y a
rappelons le aussi une question d'argent
puisque les législatives sont le nerf de
la guerre pour les partis politiques
alors hier le maire écolo de lyon
grégory doucet a ouvert les bras à jean
luc mélenchon pour lui le rassemblement
c'est maintenant écoutez le moi j'invite
bien évidemment en premier lieu jean luc
mélenchon puisque une bonne partie de
l'équation est entre ses mains
aujourd'hui il sait il s'est imposé
comme le leader ship le leader pardon de
la gauche et des écologistes à l'issue
du premier tour des présidentielles donc
bien évidemment c'est à lui maintenant
de mener
de mener les discussions pour que cette
alliance ce soit soit possible voilà
plus que cette semaine avant le premier
tour des législatives les négociations
vont s'accélérer dans les jours qui
viennent on parle d'une possible
rencontre entre socialistes et insoumis
qu'en courant de la semaine merci
beaucoup stif pour tous ces détails
suffit de ravinel vous suivez la gauche
pour pour le figaro autre journal qui
sort une info qui concerne les amis de
d'arnaud montebourg c'est ça qui
pourrait se rapprocher aussi de ceux qui
sont en train de se rapprocher pour
certains des insoumis et de jean luc
mélenchon les discussions sont en cours
mais pas remis
ce groupe l'engagement où les engagés
mais je crois que ces langages et bien
il y en a qui ne le souhaite pas et dont
notamment la socialiste laurence
rossignol qui nous a dit dans le cours
de la journée et bien ça ne me concerne
pas nous souhaitons peut-être discuter
avec les insoumis mais ça doit se faire
non pas dans le cadre d'un ralliement
mais d'une union et l'union de la gauche
ça se fait dans les règles une
discussion autour de la table selon
cette alchimie
qui a depuis toujours fait fonctionner
l'union de la gauche c'est ça ne devrait
pas changer en fait ils ne veulent pas
d'un ralliement sans conditions à jean
luc mélenchon est ce qu'ils peuvent on
voit bien chez les écologistes ça a été
très bien résumé par mon confrère chez
les écologistes et une même tension
monsieur doucet dit cela mais il est
vrai que julien bayou que j'avais en
ligne tout à l'heure me disais aussi
nous voulons une coalition ne nous ne
voulons pas nous mettre sous la bannière
de l'union populaire et donc cette
coalition évidemment les questions est
oui
son législatives qui rappellent ses
politiques en europe 1 je crois par voie
par chaque voix d'électeurs 1 par chaque
fois gagné pour les candidats mais il ya
aussi les questions européennes qui sont
un vrai sujet d'achoppement entre les
écologistes mais les insoumis faut pas
oublier quand même la guerre en ukraine
qui s'est largement invitée sur ce champ
de la gauche pendant cette campagne est
ce que vous diriez qu'il ya une question
de
personnalité de jean-luc mélenchon aussi
qu'il
est et plutôt dans une logique de
cavalier seul run et de revanche vis à
vis des partis socialistes revanche
depuis 2005 jusqu'à 2022 il y aurait un
vrai roman à écrire sur le hold up
finalement de jean-luc mélenchon
beaucoup parmi les socialistes me disent
aujourd'hui mais le ps ça n'est plus que
le prg avec tout le respect que je dois
pour le prg qui a mené un travail
séculaire et de poids le ps aujourd'hui
n'est plus que le prg n'est plus qu'un
résidu de partie je pense qu'il doit un
peu vite en besogne mais finalement il
ya quand même beaucoup de fois bien
entendu absolument est d'ailleurs
localement on pourrait voir des poches
de résistances importantes ou
législatives il n'en reste pas moins que
la direction du parti socialiste a du
mal à tenir son parti et qu'il va y
avoir ça risque d'exploser un peu dans
toutes les directions et de préfigurer
une grosse recomposition mathieu surtout
c'est un problème de culture si pour
jean luc mélenchon parce qu'on sait bien
que pour faire l'union il faut voir la
culture de l'union et jean luc mélenchon
a davantage une culture de la
vassalisation récemment qu'elle de
l'union tous comptes était ce le
compromis les discussions interminables
sur la ligne les l'émotion de synthèse
c'est tout ce qu'ils abhorrent c'est
tout ce qu'il déteste ces deux le
travail des sols fait rien qu'il a
quitté en claquant la porte donc et puis
par ailleurs pas se poser une question
de la démocratie interne au sein de la
france a soumise ne prête guère le jeu à
des formes de débat contradictoire et de
et de débats sur la ligne
il n'y a pas de discussion donc et quand
on n'est déjà pas capable de discuter
dans sa famille est ce qu'on est capable
de discuter avec avec ses cousins
éloignés ça ça me paraît compliqué a
effectivement tout quand même les
questions les questions programmatiques
il ya l'aspect carte électorale ça c'est
une chose vouloir gagner des
circonscriptions ensemble mais si on se
met ensemble pour gagner des
circonscriptions l'objectif est de
gouverner ensemble c'est-à-dire
l'objectif de jean luc mélenchon élisez
moi premier ministre donc derrière il ya
vraiment les questions programmatiques
culture politique alors si on sort on
sort des grands on va dire les grands
objectifs généraux une société plus
juste plus d'écologie plus de démocratie
d'accord mais après quand on va dans le
détail quels sont les moyens de la
justice sociale qui sont les
bénéficiaires de la juste social pour
quel ordre tout ça se fait en respectant
ou non les contraintes européennes on
voit qu'il ya des automatismes les
encore et doit-on ou non sortir de
l'otan que des accords qui sont majeurs
et qui expliquent la situation de
division à gauche qui n'est pas le
produit de gens qui sont en rivalité
personnelle ça peut jouer évidemment
mais c'est des accords programmatiques
frédéric dabi si on essaie de se
projeter là vers les législatives il ya
c'est très compliqué de aujourd'hui de
d'imaginer ce qui pourrait se passer on
connaît pas encore les listes précises
de deux candidats les les les
tractations sur les éventuels accords
entre entre partis politiques mais il ya
quand même 7 ce qui était la tradition
d'un effet je sais pas positif ou d'un
effet de souffle oui c'est le terme que
vous employez ça pourrait quand même
même s'il sera peut-être plus faible
profité au camp ma crème je pense que ce
sera quand même la tendance puisque on
l'a vu à chaque élections législatives
suivant une élection présidentielle
depuis 1980 où déjà leaders de droite
espérait avec lui nm compenser le veau
des sons présidentiel en inde du comment
ça s'est terminé et puis l'instauration
du quinquennat et de l'inversion du
calendrier électoral cet effet de
souffle a soufflé systématiquement et
parfois extrêmement fort là il ya des
éléments de nuances d'abord cette
campagne législative qui commence très
fortement de la part des oppositions
c'est le deuxième mandat d' emmanuel
macron sa majorité présidentielle c'est
un majorité parlementaire note ne s'est
pas forgé formidablement implanté et
puis j'ai été surpris par une enquête de
notre sondage ce jour du vote ifop
fiducial une question pardon ou deux
tiers des français inscrits en est ce
qu'ils iront voter c'est la vraie
question
souhaite que les oppositions puisse
imposer une coiffe une cohabitation j'ai
des confrères ont trouvé une tendance
équivalente maintenant ce qui va être
centrales au delà des tractations de
l'implantation des sortants c'est la
participation entre la participation au
premier tour de la présidentielle 2017
et premier tour des législatives
on a perdu 24 ou 25 points c'est ça qui
était autour de 50% par réalisation se
situe historiquement pour la première
fois une élection nationale et
législatives l'abstention a été
majoritaire c'est l'enjeu pour
les camps des candidats défaits jean luc
mélenchon marine le pen eric zemmour et
le reste de la gauche de pouvoir re
mobiliser leur électorat et c'est un
enjeu colossal
se maintenir au second tour il il faut
réunir 12 % et 56 abstentions
attention il faut faire 25 % vient cette
version est réinventera mois ce qui est
ce qui est ce qui s'était passé en 2010
elle est maire donc ça veut dire que le
premier chiffre une autre est ce qu'on
va devoir surveiller dans les prochaines
semaines c'est celui de l'abstention la
première édition c'est le juge de paix
d'une certaine manière puisque on voit
que ça fixe qui peut se maintenir au
deuxième tour et c'est vrai ça détermine
s'il ya des triangulaires et on voit que
plus l'abstention est importante plus le
ticket d'entrée au deuxième tour est
important suffrages exprimés et c'est
vrai que ça accentue aussi les
disparités territoriales là où il ya des
forces politiques qui ont des bastions
ils ont des possibilités d'avoir des
candidats qui ont 7 ce niveau de
performance et puis sinon s'explique
aussi le gros différentiel avec la
présidentielle à ckoi conscription
unique de la présidentielle ne se
répliquent pas forcément dans les 577
circonscriptions législatives se fit de
ravinel pour emmanuel macron il ya un
homme qui pourrait jouer un rôle
important dans les prochaines semaines
c'est françois rebsamen le maire de
dijon pour essayer de créer à gauche un
parti une espèce de dément pour des
socialistes qui n'iraient pas vers vers
jean luc mélenchon seulement france avec
ses rennes en tout cas à la volonté de
commencer à construire cela pour le chef
de l'état dans cette idée d'union
nationale voilà et puis cette idée
surtout de sauvegarder la social
démocratie avec l'idée évidemment comme
pour tous dans ce camp-là de l'échiquier
politique que c'est là près 1e macro qui
est en train de se construire il ne
croit pas vraiment un troisième mandat
possible malgré des réformes éventuelles
institutionnel mais en tout cas l'idée
dire il faut reconstruire un pôle social
démocrate fort pour s'opposer à un
edouard philippe pour s'opposer année à
celui qui sera le
successeur de d'emmanuel macron à droite
au centre droit donc ça c'est une chose
ensuite est-ce que c'est françois
rebsamen qui va le mener je ne sais pas
il ya un papier que je vous recommande
de main et qui est tout à fait
sympathique et passionnant de mes
confrères françois-xavier bourmaud et
arthur berda dans le figaro dans lequel
on apprend par exemple le cas ni d'alcoa
a refusé de faire illuminé la tour
eiffel hier soir pour ne pas que
emmanuel macron en profite des tas de
petites choses qui font les détails
croustillants d'une vie politique un peu
parfois amer mais on apprend aussi que
il y a des noms à gauche qui circulent
qui seraient 10 ont dans le viseur et on
en entend parler de bernard cazenave les
relations ce serait un petit peu
réchauffées avec emmanuel macron cd
glacial elle était glaciale mêmes mots
et moi c'est pour ça que ça m'étonne à
titre personnel mais peut-être que c'est
tout à fait le cas je suppose parce que
au lancement de la campagne des médias
locaux il était très très dure vis-à-vis
des manuels macro mais sait-on jamais on
l'a très bien souligné tout à l'heure il
va y avoir quatre ou cinq ans sans
élection le temps est long et certains
peuvent avoir envie de participer à
l'état de la nation allez un dernier
chapitre dans notre débat qu'on pourrait
intituler madame le premier ministre le
choix de celui ou celle qui prendra la
suite de jean castex à matignon serait
évidemment cruciale pour emmanuel macron
est alors parmi les noms qui circulent
il ya celui d'elisabeth bornes l'actuel
ministre du travail à l'été sur rtl ce
matin devrais je vous ai appelé madame
la première ministre madame le premier
ministre dans les prochains jours je
crois que c'est pas le sujet vous savez
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
d'entendre le message des français leurs
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat leurs
attentes sur l'écologie j'ai pas de
doute qu emmanuel macron tour à l'équipe
pour mener ce projet mathieu c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle d'être la
favorite des médias ou le favori des
médias j'ai géré à manger vous pouvez
pas mieux flinguer quelqu'un que de
raison
surtout huit jours avant 15 jours avant
c'est généralement il peut y avoir des
leurs est la règle n'est pas tout à fait
exact parce que de françois fillon on
savait que ce serait dur mais c'est
elisabeth borne n'a pas tenu le même
rôle dans la campagne des modèles macron
que françois fillon avait tenu dans la
campagne de nicolas sarkozy les aveux de
marne on a des atouts pour elle c'est
qu'elle est plutôt issus des rangs de la
gauche elle a était préfète de la région
poitou charentes c'est là où elle a
rencontré ses
valises de cabinet
elle connaît l'appareil delta c'est une
techno techno voie lactée ministres
écologie à l'écologie et c'est une femme
c'est bien que du coup ça ça fait
beaucoup de cases cochées après n'a
jamais été élu et c'est pas vraiment une
politique qu'elle a su mener des
réformes dans chacun des ministères qui
a occupé que ce soit aux transports ou à
l'écologie mais c'est pas quelqu'un de
politique or faut quand même rappeler
que le premier ministre a même si
emmanuel macron a revu un peu la façon
de l'exercer les rôles c'est quand même
le chef de la majorité et que là il ya
un combat à mener pour la majorité qu
est celui des législatives bruno cautrès
le profil de celui ou celle qui
succédera à jean castex c'est sûr que
c'est un profil de ceux de ce type là
que si emmanuel macron veut surprendre
il faut qu'ils prennent un profil en
dehors du rang des rangs des anciens
républicains puisque ses deux premiers
ministres étaient issus des républicains
edouard philippe et jean castex donc si
emmanuel macron faut montrer qu'à macro
deux cas un nouveau message politique ce
sera un peu difficile de prendre à
nouveau quelqu'un qui serait directement
issus des rangs des républicains
vas y vas où elle va mener le combat des
premiers c'est quand même une fonction
très politique dans le cas d'edouard
philippe et jean castex et quand même
des gens qui ont effectivement passé
politique important avant d'accéder à
ces ca ca ses fonctions ces chefs de la
majorité il faut trouver aussi quelqu'un
qui se retrouve bien dans cette équation
qui va être d'essayer de faire tenir ce
qu'emmanuel là qu'on a raconté aux
français dans l'entre-deux tours et hier
soir c'est à dire quelqu'un qui a qui
qui qui qui a une vision qui lui permet
de tenir tout ça et de faire tenir
ensemble d'une majorité qui s'annonce
peut-être beaucoup plus diversifiée et
hétérogène que ce n'était le cas en
terme de composition du demain qu'en
2010 année avec un emmanuel macron cas
beaucoup promis qu'à beaucoup elle est
bloquée dans les comics a beaucoup
promis pendant cette campagne dans la
dernière ligne droite en voulant couvrir
beaucoup d'attentes et de frustration et
de tension de la société française et
donc faut trouver l'oiseau rare qui
arrive à
conclure juste un tout petit mot pour
dire que dans nos pages de nouveau très
corporate ce soit mais de fait sa vive
le travail est bien fait il faut lever
et bien vous lirez l'interview de
françois bayroux demain dans le figaro
jean ce qu'il sait à qui il faut penser
il
dirait une toute petite phrase les
mondes 2017 il ya des dizaines de noms
qui sont sortis dans la presse sur
matignon sauf un solide et doit philippe
bon ben on verra bien si ça se fait
attendre soyons prudents on essaye
d'être prudent dans cette émission merci
beaucoup à tous les trois d'avoir
participé à ce
débat dans